Chester is an historic city in the
northwest of England which is famous for
its Roman and Saxon city walls and the
rows which are unique elevated walkways
above the city centre the city has
employed a full time access officer
since 1991
all sections of the famous rows and most
of the three kilometres of the walls are
accessible via a combination of ramps
level access routes lifts and an
escalator new handrails and tactile
paving are also used for special
changing places facilities have been
provided to enable people with
disabilities to visit the city for
longer periods all of the city's 192
taxis and 129 buses are wheelchair
accessible ability angels provide
shopping companions the council goes
beyond what is required by law to ensure
that disabled people can visit and enjoy
the city the city seeks feedback on its
accessibility issues from groups
supporting people with intellectual
disabilities traders and the local
council report that improving
accessibility has brought increased
numbers of older visitors and visitors
with disabilities to the cities shops
leisure and heritage facilities this has
boosted the local economy today we
reward Chester with first prize in the
EU access city award for how it has made
the historic centre fully accessible and
for recognizing and illustrating that it
makes economic sense to invest in
accessibility
you